what is a fuku burger what makes it so
special well you decided it's the best
in the valley that's right and fuku
burger in fact as you know won our
Burger bracket that we had here on 8
news now for March Madness yes we're now
in April but we still like the food and
we still like Lauren negretti who's
having some of it at the Southwest
Valley uh restaurant Buffalo and Warm
Springs Lauren good morning to you
good morning High Praise thank you John
yes fuku burger while fuku actually
means lucky we you guys talk about that
yeah yeah that's part of my last name
fuku and Japanese means luck you see it
on all the slot machines in the casinos
you know all over all over the casinos
because it does bringing luck has done
for us it sure has yeah calling fukunaga
um owner and then here mags also Chef
mags I should say hello Max also means
it's just max
thanks for that so okay like you said
look you guys beat out 63 other burger
places uh but you guys got more than
just Burgers here we got our chicken
katsu here chicken katsu sandwich
shredded cabbage crack sauce and katsu
sauce
and so and then call in here as your
face is just smooshed against the
chicken uh you are also you know really
looking at some future expansion here
but maybe down the line yeah yeah well
we always want to keep it a Vegas secret
probably not going to ever go out of
Vegas ever again
um Northwest maybe Centennial area and
then definitely handled we've been
getting a lot of people asking us to go
to Henderson so that's definitely on the
horizons and quickly here you know like
we said the community we asked the
community which ones you guys are such a
pillar in the community and to hear that
you guys kind of won and beat out these
other places you know how's that feel
for you guys thank you Vegas this is
awesome it's a huge honor that you know
you guys voted for your local local
Brands it's I mean just to even be
mentioned in the 64 is awesome but to be
against in and out which has always been
my my North Star is awesome just to be
in there and we beat them that's us all
local local love that's right local love
lots of love for you guys today thank
you so much well I don't have to tell
you guys just how much we love these the
food here back to you yeah I love the
katsu Burger that's my move that is
that's your order right okay oh my gosh
and fuku means lucky I I did not know
that that is so cool so now we know why
they won they're so lucky that they made
these incredible Burgers they put it in
the system